hey my name is leslie odom jr eli gray
kingsley bennett there
this is aldous hodge and this is how i
became jim brown i became malcolm x
became cash's club and this is how i
became sam cook
i remember when i was a little boy my
dad pointed out to me one time
the swan little family of swans was
grazing
you know or was was uh slowly like you
know
going like that across the the uh
on the water top of the water and uh he
said do you see those and
yeah sure he said so you see how
graceful they look he said underneath
the water
you know talking about the the amount of
effort
underneath grace the amount of
effort underneath what sam
had crafted uh which was this
unflappable
smooth professional sexy
you know appealing thing you know
there was great effort
um holding that all together and
racking up those accomplishments that is
that is the strength of a
vision so i say that to say the thing
that i learned
uh most about him in my discovery it's
right there in kemp's script
and as i went to do the research i
discovered oh that's why you put it in
there
sam wanted nothing to play with sam was
a fire brand
like nobody was pushing sam around
anywhere
ever so yeah i wanted that side of him
shown
not just the not just that that calm
exterior that we known for
well this is all to a hopping star
whenever stepping into the shoes of
someone who is real
you want to do your best to honor this
person and respect their legacy
and really celebrate what they've done
and for me at first i didn't know if i
was up to the to the charge i didn't
know if i could be him i was looking i
was studying i was like can i be
this guy i don't know right so you know
i didn't know but after uh
the audition came around uh the
opportunity to audition came around a
couple times i was like you know what
let me step into this give it a shot
because
there's a reason it's coming back around
so i auditioned and um
during that process i really just looked
at
at who he was i studied as much uh
information as i could when it came to
videos and
interviews and studying his cadence and
how he spoke and how he moved and even
how he handled
altercation but mostly it was about
understanding his mentality
to really get into the mindset and the
essence of you know mr brown
it's nice ain't about it it's most
definitely soothing cass
[Music]
i started kind of working on the
character a while before
this film even i had another opportunity
to do an
audition for another film that i didn't
get so i just i was working on the
character for a while
but um i was looking for a dialect coach
and a producer from a film i
had worked on before called race i was
asking her if she knew any good dialect
coaches and she introduced me to someone
who introduced me to trey
and we worked together from the first
time i'd heard about the audition
until i got to meet regina and then all
the way through
the shooting process so it was pretty
long it was like you know
nine months that we were just like
working
three times a week for an hour and a
half you know
um and then when we were on set probably
even more than that like every day
for about an hour and we really nailed
down the southern accent and he kind of
helped me to understand the culture of
the south and how that affects the voice
and how that affects
the perspective of a young black man um
i think that helped me really get into
the skin or
embody where where cacious was coming
from from the roots
and then when we put everything else on
top of that foundation it just felt
very grounded and very natural um so i
think that's probably when i really felt
like i had a handle on
just the southern accent there was a
phrase that i it was like a phrase that
he says
all the time to champ we're all coming
back here for the chance of victory paul
don't be late it never felt right coming
out of my mouth
like i'm the champ you know i'm the
world's champ and it was just like for
some reason it was just it was just
awkward
for a long time and there would be times
when i would say it i'd just be like did
that sound right to you did that sound
real or authentic and then you know
after a while it became more comfortable
but um
yeah for some reason champ just like
many times
just didn't quite feel right i figured i
better start getting my life story
documented in my own words while i can
[Music]
i think a really important moment was
was in in the reading of it before i'd
even attempted to
ingest any of the language or attempt
any of the dialect it was
it was reading kemp's words and really
trying to understand from an acting
point of view like what the function of
malcolm was within this piece
and then i read it again and i was like
the emotional and the current
you know his heartbeat his there's a
vulnerability about him in the words
that felt very unique and
and i was like guys this is an
opportunity to kind of play or explore
you know malcolm in a really different
way
and then i started sort of investigating
what the stakes actually were for
malcolm at this
particular moment in time and he he was
on a ban and and
there was a real sense that he was being
pushed out of the nation of islam and
that his
his days were were numbered i think he
was beginning to understand that and
there was a real sense that his life was
you know about to be in real danger i'm
not sure if the
the death threats were kind of just
starting to happen the fbi were really
up his arse you know in a big way they
were they were onto him
and uh i think that was
that was understanding all of that
before anything was the most important
thing and regina and i
you know when we jumped on the phone
after she saw my
sort of interpretation in my audition
tapes that's what we spoke about we
spoke about
malcolm and the father and the husband
and the vulnerability of
his situation at this time was was
everything and then it just
you know then it was just a pure joy
because i i
was kind of set free by uh lots of
dick gregory's words on malcolm and
dick said that malcolm had confided in
him around this time and and said that
he
he felt weak and he felt hollow and and
no one knew
the torments that he went through as you
know his relationship with the nation
was
was ending and and uh and dick said that
he
you know if malcolm could hear us now
he'd be embarrassed
he was really a sweet and bashful man
and and the lacerating demagogue that we
all know that
kind of stereotypical image was really
really a character that malcolm slipped
in and out of but wasn't the sum total
of who he was and when we do see malcolm
on youtube in those you know those those
classic images of him
so often it's malcolm in response to the
most
hideous instances of racism have
just happened that day or the day before
you know and we kind of
you know that that image is really
what so many people know of him but i
was really excited about the opportunity
to explore
uh that other side
we want the world
[Music]
there was one interview like i watched
so many documentaries something you know
antoine who quoted a great one called
what's my name and there's the spike lee
classic when we were kings and i watched
lots of interviews and i read books um
you know blood brothers was the book
that i went to um that gave me a lot of
information
but probably every day for at least
three months
there was an interview that i found on
youtube
of him when he's about 20 years old
before he had his first professional
uh his first championship fight on local
louisville
radio um just a ha uh a
interview with a fighter and people were
just calling in asking him
asking him questions for about an hour
and a half um and it was really really
cool because you learned so much about
how he had to balance this persona with
the reality of being a black man in the
south
and um you know he was just really he
was so smart there was a there's the
moment
i was probably listening to it for about
two weeks every morning
before i realized that there's a moment
where
there's a kkk member who calls in and
you don't i didn't realize it at first
but when you listen back and listen back
then you realize that he's
he's threatening him in code and cassius
is trying to maintain
his disposition this really happens you
can go look it up um
his disposition as this braggadocious
champ
but at the same time realizing his life
is on the line if he's once he steps
outside of this
radio station in the way he maneuvers
the conversation and manages answers
these questions
was just he's a genius you know at such
a young age so
wise beyond his years um so that was an
interview that i listen to
every day for months and months and
months not just for the dialect but just
also to see how his mind operated and
how he processed things and how he
overcame challenges
and how he interacted with fans there
was just so many so many gems in that
interview
the goal is for us to really be free i
wanted to showcase
uh the strength and confidence of
knowing himself and knowing his value
when i did research i realized how
how forthcoming he was rather forthright
he was about
understanding who he was in this time in
a space where a lot of people
openly spoke against him um because of
the color of his skin
um you know they celebrated him on the
field but oh you know spoke against him
behind closed doors
but he didn't let that deteriorate he
only allowed it to push him
forward and understand and even share
the value of
taking control of his narrative his
understanding of economic power within
the community he allowed it to motivate
him
for progress so i really wanted to
display that side of this man who really
was quite
intellectual on the subject of what it
means when it comes to
getting control of your potential and
completely taking charge and pushing
forward but we are fighting for our
lives
you know i know what's going on out
there right
well leslie and i before we started
shooting that stuff we kind of
agreed you know between us quietly that
we were
we were both open to to kind of throwing
each other and trying things out and
playing games and
you know just staying open to the ad the
possibility of of
of surprising each other and and it was
kind of tough at times and when we we
went in and especially i went really
hard and heavy on leslie in that first
week
and that we shot that scene in the room
first and i sort of took no prisoners
and and laid into him
relentlessly for a week and there was
something really interesting about that
it was kind of difficult and
uncomfortable because we didn't know
each other and it was really the first
few days of filming
um but yeah leslie and i uh
was a it was yeah it was a joy to get to
to really try and bring those scenes to
life with him
everything's not so black and white like
you make it out to be i mean
the argument was all laid out for us and
kemp's
beautiful script i recognized that that
kemp wanted to do something daring he
wanted to have a
private conversation publicly these are
conversations that i
witnessed first as a boy i witnessed my
parents and adults around me having
conversations like this and as an adult
i started to have them myself
and uh
and and there was something a little
dangerous about this script i couldn't
quite put my finger on it
because usually the way that we push
boundaries in film
are i mean the usual ways i think are
probably like violence
or sex you know it's very rare
is is a is a boundary pushed in film
through an argument through talking
um dialogue so i thought that was really
exciting um
and yeah it's just uh i guess the
age-old
back and forth of ken you know is the
only way to change things you know the
other people that believe you have you
can only change things from the inside
and there's the other adage that says
you know
um you have to divest you can't build
anything worthwhile
in your master's house you know that you
have to go and
build your own thing outside of that so
uh it's a
real push and pull the only
not fight that i had with with brother
kemp but i remember you know because
kingsley as malcolm have been coming at
me in that hotel room for days before i
got to respond
uh my just just laying into me and
um you know there's really nowhere for
that to go for that tension
until you get to respond the tension
just lives in your body so there's this
one weekend before i shot
my side of the argument and i was like
kemp i need more
you got it like because because malcolm
has compelling arguments he's brilliant
and kingsley's brilliant at playing your
record is going to stand the test of
time
[Music]
for me to widen out my face i wore these
plumpers which i fit between
my jaws on both sides so it made it a
little interesting to try to eat
but i had those in my my mouth all day
to
speak and you know try to give me a
little round out so you know you kind of
have to work around how you how you
speak with
that because it's like basically having
a weird set of braces
and yeah they they sometimes they
painted on some of the scars but i
actually have some bumpy knuckles
so some of that was real good that was
real and then i just had to you know uh
size up a little bit i had to get the
gym a little bit more for
for for because you know when the small
brother you know he was swole so
i had to get up in there with the
push-ups you know i'm confident uh
in my skill set but i a part of that
confidence comes a little bit
of assurance comes afterwards while i'm
working i'm always maintaining the fact
that i need to do the work and i never
get comfortable
so i never had a moment where i said you
know all right i'm in it i meant this is
it you know i felt like
keep up the work never let your guard
down uh
keep going because you can do better you
can do more you can keep pushing further
and that's that sort of repetition
allows me to stay in the
the constant state of doing work so i
can keep practicing you know who he is
oh my goodness okay
what okay
why am i so pretty ah i hired trey
personally out of my own before i had
the role i hired him as my dialect coach
i just said i know i'm gonna
i believe i'm gonna play this role and
you know and he thank god was like
okay i'm on board let's do it you know
and so i was paying him out of pocket
um for before i had the role for months
and then when i got the role
thank god they brought him on as the
dialect coach for the film and then he
you know he was a blessing to all of us
from then um but you know and same thing
with the boxing like i was training at
eastside boxing center when i was
in vancouver when i would shoot on
riverdale and then when i'd be in la
i would go to different boxing clubs
around la
um you know there was a ufc gym out in
torrance where i where i worked with
guys
um there's uh mario i can't remember his
name but he's um
gabriel rosado's personal trainer um you
know he helped me with my boxing stuff
you know i just anybody i knew that knew
anything about boxing
i was i would try to do anything i could
just pick up anything i could because i
knew i wanted to play this role
and then um from when i got the role
i got introduced to rob sally who you
know did the fight choreography for
creed and for the clarisha shields
story and is you know a former
professional fighter a current
professional fight coach and uh was just
phenomenal and
has been a wealth of knowledge ever
since all together
yeah no that was it's a weird thing for
actors because we look in a script and
you see something like that a moment and
then you know sam sings the change is
going to come on tonight's show you're
like
i want to do that and then right on the
flip side of you you're like
but no time soon though like but make
that as late as possible and so
since this is about becoming um i'll say
on that day that was my last day of
shooting in new orleans
and sam was never closer to me than he
was
on that day and that is because
the way i became sam the way that i
found my
sam was through the interrogation
of kingsley benadir as malcolm x through
those relationships that i developed
with jim and cassius and those you know
my brothers on on that set
they helped tell me who i was supposed
to be
i i was sam in relation to these three
other guys
look at this view wow
i bet they're doing them for me
you